well it's been a very nice conference so
our closing keynote speaker is dr.
Pachauri dr. Pretorius and Nobel
laureate yay chairman of the IPCC that
you are for sure and the founding
director of the YC I he's also director
general of the energy and resources
institute I mean come on you know his
efforts and work with the IPCC has
focused the world's attention on the
severity of manmade climate change and
he's really provided the critical
scientific information necessary for our
leaders and our policymakers to make the
informed and mature decisions that
ultimately would benefit everyone if
they're willing to take that that path
so please let me just introduce dr.
Pachauri and let's all welcome
thank you very much mark it's such a
pleasure to be here and thank you for
giving me this opportunity well I have
about 30 minutes in which I'm going to
make a powerpoint presentation to you
and I don't know if there'll be time for
questions and answers but I'll try to
make it a bit shorter so they're at
least you have a few minutes to ask any
critical questions that you have in mind
I'll start with the first slide and this
of course is at the heart of what
climate change is all about they've been
scientists going back 150 years who have
been telling us about the consequences
of increase in carbon dioxide
concentration in the Earth's atmosphere
in terms of change in climate but I
think for a long period of time the
world sort of ignored them and therefore
I think we were really living in a state
of ignorance and we caused a problem
which is very well expressed in this
brief quotation from Albert Einstein
just to give you an indication of what's
been happening with emissions of
greenhouse gases and I'll say a lot more
later on urine since 1970 up to twenty
ten the emissions that have taken place
constitute fifty percent of the total
emissions since the beginning of
industrialization so in a sense not only
have we ignored knowledge and not only
has a weariness being deficient but it's
actually in some sense become even worse
let me go on to why I'm saying so you
know there's a ninety-five percent
certainty that human influence has been
the dominant cause of observed warning
warming since the mid 20th century we
use the term extremely likely
that this statement is correct and when
we talk about extremely likely we are
assigning a probability of over
ninety-five percent in the previous
assessment report that's the fourth
assessment report we use the term very
likely which represented a probability
of over ninety percent so this is where
I would say our understanding our
knowledge and our confidence in the
findings that we have come up with in
the past has certainly increased
substantially and since the mid 1950s
many of these are observed changes are
unprecedented over decades to millennia
so in a short period of time obviously
we have had much to do that really pales
into insignificance what has happened
over belinea and limited lyman change
will require sustained and substantial
reductions in greenhouse gas emissions
and I'll say more on that now each of
the last three decades has been
successively warmer at the Earth's
surface then any preceding decade since
1850 and about a month ago the world
meteorological organization has come out
with a major statement they bring this
out annually which mentions as a matter
of fact that 2011 tied with 2006 as the
warmest year since records have been
maintained oceans have warmed and risen
the amounts of snow and ice of
diminished sea level has risen and the
concentrations of GHGs have increased
now as it happens ocean warming
dominates the increase in energy stored
in the climate system more than ninety
percent of energy accumulated between
1971 and 2010 is accounted for with the
increase in heat in the oceans so in a
sense this has been moderating influence
otherwise surface temperatures would
have been substantially higher and the
rate of sea level rise since the mid
19th century has been larger than the
mean rate during the previous two
millennia and between 1901 and 2010 the
global mean sea level rose by 19
centimeters now that's pretty close to a
foot and here may I say that it's not
the fact that large parts of the world
are being inundated but even before that
happens storm surges coastal flooding
are going to play havoc into several
parts of the world you take another
example you know this is something on
which I was criticized for because
people twist things around you know we
had this terrible tsunami in Japan if
the sea level had been lower let's say
where it was over a hundred years ago
the extent of damage and devastation
would have been much less because higher
this the higher the sea level the
greater would be the damage way with any
of these events no matter what the cause
might be and of course there's some
motivated people in the media who said
that the chairman of the IPCC says that
the tsunami was caused by climate change
but that's good reporting so i would say
different I mean it makes headlines okay
the atmospheric concentrations of co2
methane and nitrous oxide have increased
to levels unprecedented in at least the
past eight hundred thousand years and in
the previous report we had assigned a
figure of 650,000 years but now we are
absolutely certain that these levels
have not occurred for 800,000 years and
the oceans of course are acidifying at a
very rapid rate because thirty percent
of the emitted anthropogenic carbon
dioxide has been absorbed by the oceans
and frankly this is an area in which
enough research has been not conducted
so far so we really don't know what the
impact would be on marine ecosystems on
marine species we do know that it's
affecting coral reefs in a harmful way
but there's a lot more to be done in
this area and co2 emissions from fossil
fuels combustion and industrial
processes contributed about seventy
eight percent of the total GHG emissions
increase from 1972 2010 so about seventy
eight percent of the emissions from
these two sets of sources it has has
been accounted for by by these
particular sources of emissions this is
just a quick picture and I'm sure all of
you are familiar with this but the one
thing that I'd like to point out for
your information is the agriculture
forestry and land use related emissions
now one of the things that we've done
and I'll mention this a little later in
the Working Group three report that was
brought out a week ago is to highlight
the importance of this particular sector
really being able to reduce emissions of
greenhouse gases I mean thus far people
have only concentrated on established
industrial energy related transport and
other sources of emissions but this is
also a major source where we need to
bring about some major changes oceans we
know will continue to warm during the
21st century and you know you have to
accept the fact that there are there is
an enormous amount of inertia and the
whole system quite apart from the fact
that we have inertia in our minds as
well we don't change easily but there's
a lot of infrastructure they are
processes their technologies that are
geared to use of conventional forms of
energy supply that use all kinds of
resources in a particular manner and all
of this will have to change but there's
always a set of barriers to change there
are always delays and therefore you
would say that there is an inertia and
it's very likely that the Arctic sea ice
cover will continue to shrink and thin
as global mean surface temperature rises
then I'll be going there again I've been
to the Arctic region a few times I'm
going there again at the end of next
month global glaceon volume will further
decrease
noble mean sea level will continue to
rise during the 21st century and I'll
give you some numbers on that the other
point that I'd like to make is that
climate change is not a slow smooth and
steady system climate change is going to
be accompanied is being accompanied by a
whole set of extreme events it's very
likely that the length frequency as well
as intensity of warm spells or heat
waves will increase over most land areas
and in fact we've got certain scenarios
under which we assess that let's say a 1
in 20 year hottest day is likely to
become a one in two year event in most
regions if we don't mitigate emissions
of greenhouse gases it's also likely
that the frequency of heavy
precipitation or the proportion of total
rainfall from heavy falls will increase
over many areas of the globe in fact so
much so that in those parts of the world
where you have a decline in average
precipitation a large part of it will
take place in the form of heavy falls so
these are things which not only pose
hazards for life and property but they
also have major implications on the
availability and accessibility of water
resources these are just some quick
tabulations of impacts that I wanted to
bring to your attention freshwater
resources there would be a reduction of
surface as well as groundwater resources
in many dry subtropical regions and
climate change is projected to pose
risks to raw and drinking water quality
because what's also happening at the
same time is that the quality of water
is being affected but once the volumes
decrease then clearly the concentration
of pollution in a lot of this stock is
also going to increase correspondingly
increased extinction risk under all
warming scenarios as far as freshwater
ecosystems are concerned increased tree
mortality forests die back with risks
for carbon storage
some urgent and coastal flooding which I
mentioned a while ago marine systems
there will be a redistribution and
reduction of global marine species I'll
just give you an example and this is a
purely anecdotal I mean the last time i
went to the Maldive islands which
incidentally have been a major exporter
of tuna fish they mentioned that the
stock of tuna that they were accustomed
to is just not available anymore because
a lot of that fish has moved to other
areas which are now less warm than that
surrounding area and this is happening
with a number of species in fact we in
the working group to report we have got
a diagram which shows the speed of
migration of different sets of species
these are both plant as well as animal
species that are moving not to speak of
marine species expansion of dead zones
will increase will take place with
constraints for fish habitat and polar
ecosystems and coral reefs are at
substantial risk food security and
production systems these are going to be
affected because the impacts on
agriculture in fact we have estimated
for the major crops what is going to be
the impact of a one degree increase in
temperature two-degree increase in
temperature and so on and overall the
net effect is going to be negative now
this is something that I'd like to
highlight because this is going to be
most prominent in those parts of the
world where people essentially produce
just about enough food to take care of
their own needs now if they're going to
be affected by decline in agricultural
yields then you can imagine that has
very serious implications for both
nutrition as well as hunger so there
will be under nutrition from reduced
food production in poor reaches and
there'll be increased risks from food
and water borne diseases now what we
really need is a combination of
adaptation and mitigation because we
will have to adapt to the impacts of
climate
there's a as I mentioned a certain
inertia in the system there are time
lags even if we were to bring about a
radical reduction in emissions today
there is a certain inertia in the system
as a result of which for several decades
climate change will continue and the
impacts will will also therefore
continue and therefore we have no choice
but to adapt to a certain level of
impacts of climate change since
mitigation reduces the rate and
magnitude of warming it also increases
the time available for adaptation to a
particular level of climate change
potentially by several decades what's
also most important is that if we
mitigate then we can avoid some of the
worst impacts of climate change if we
don't mitigate then not only is there
going to be a much faster rate at which
at which these impacts will appear but
some of them which perhaps could be
eliminated will be quite dominant now in
baseline scenarios those without
additional mitigation efforts we found
that direct co2 emissions from the
energy supply sector I expected to
almost double or even triple by 2050
compared to 2010 so we're on a pathway
by which emissions are increasing very
rapidly and this clearly is something
that should impel us towards taking
action and steps by which we reduce
these emissions in the future this
results in significant increases in
indirect emissions from electricity use
in the buildings and industry sectors
you can imagine that with greater
warming there'll be a greater demand for
air conditioning and space conditioning
of various kinds i also want to mention
that infrastructure developments and
long-lived products that lock societies
into ghe intensive emissions pathways
may be difficult or very costly to
change an example is buildings now this
of course is a unique building which has
been designed to ensure that you
minimize the use of energy of various
kinds particularly fossil fuel based
energy but on the other hand
there are large number of buildings
which have an economic life of 5060
sometimes many more years in those cases
you really can't bring about any changes
yes there is some scope for retrofitting
but that leave you very small benefits
in terms of reduced emissions and
therefore it's important for us to
design buildings at the initial stage
itself which ensure high levels of
efficiency we'll have to lower global
GHGs in 2050 than in 2010 42 seventy
percent lower globally emission levels
near zero gigatonnes for co2 equivalent
or below in 2100 so basically what this
is saying is that if we really want to
limit temperature increase to say 2
degrees Celsius and that involves
reaching and maintaining levels no more
than 450 parts per million of co2
equivalent then it's essential for us to
start sucking in carbon dioxide before
the end of this century and that's not
impossible that's not something which is
unreasonable one of the things that
we've highlighted is as I mentioned
earlier forestry act activities reducing
deforestation reducing emissions from
agriculture and so on the other thing
that's very significant over here is the
third item that's mentioned tripling to
nearly a quadrupling of the share of
zero and low-carbon energy supply from
renewables by 2050 so we have 36 years
in which to bring this about now that
won't happen by itself we've got to put
in place policies by which business
industry and other stakeholders get very
clear signals that they've got to invest
invest in research and development and
have to ensure the development and
dissemination of some of these
technologies nuclear energy biome
as fossil energy with carbon capture and
storage and bioenergy with carbon
capture and storage by the year 2050 are
the options that we have and the IPCC
doesn't do any policy prescriptive work
so we're not recommending one or the
other but these are available as choices
for global society and we love to
exercise our choices based on what we
perceive as best for a particular
country now if you look at technological
opportunities there are many scenarios
by which you can reach 450 500 or 50 550
parts per million of co2 equivalent by
2100 but this would require availability
and widespread deployment of bioenergy
carbon capture and storage and a
forestation post 2050 so in other words
you could have overshoot scenarios you
could overshoot the 450 target that
would stabilize temperature increase to
two degree Celsius but then you'll have
to take very stringent action and deploy
technologies by which you can bring
about a much more rapid reduction in
greenhouse gas emissions so there's a
whole range of trajectories or pathways
that one can think of but we must keep
in mind the fact that if we allow delays
to take place now then clearly the costs
of action subsequently will be
substantially higher so the availability
and scale of these and other carbon
reduction technologies are uncertain and
associated with challenges and risks
mitigation scenarios reaching around 450
parts per million co2 equivalent
concentrations by 2100 show large-scale
global changes in the energy supply
sector now these would involve systemic
and cross-sectoral mitigation strategies
that are most cost-effective in cutting
emissions than a focus on in
technologies in sectors just to give you
an indication I mean you could have
specific policies let's say for the
transport sector but but that may or may
not be as effective as let's say coming
up with a price on carbon because when
you do that then that that has a major
impact not only on transport it will
have an impact on processes on products
on technologies all of which will be
driven by this consideration of low
carbon intensity and at the energy
system level these include reductions in
the emissions emissions in intensity in
the energy supply sector a switch to
low-carbon energy carriers reductions in
energy demand in the end you sectors
without compromising development so this
is important I think human society is
certainly not going to bring about any
of these actions by consigning us to a
situation where we have to start living
in caves and wrapping ourselves in
sheepskin I think basically we need to
bring about a transition by which there
is no radical change in those things
that the world has become accustomed to
although I should emphasize that
lifestyle changes behavioral changes are
going to play a crucial role in the
future and what are these just to give
you an example if you look at Europe I
mean you go to the Netherlands you find
everyone going around on a bicycle and
you've got excellent public transport
people go from one place to the other 45
minutes away they carry their bicycles
with them when they get off the train
they jump on their bike and they're off
to wherever they have to go now that's a
major behavioural change similarly I
would say even the use of lighting in
homes and you know this is something
that Michelle addington taught me three
or four years ago I mean in this country
that is obviously an excessive amount of
lighting in several applications now you
therefore really need to
come up with regulations that would make
a difference this is also true of the
building sector if there were local
bodies that laid down benchmarks and
laid down regulations by which buildings
were made more efficient then things
would certainly move in the right
direction and reductions in energy
demand in the end user sectors without
compromising development I'm sorry I got
that long now this will give us more
flexibility for reducing carbon
intensity in the energy supply sector if
we were to reduce demand then clearly we
have a little more elbow room to bring
about changes on the supply side and
hedge against related supply-side risk
there are issues of energy security that
we need to be conscious of avoid locking
to carbon intensive infrastructure and
these are of course are associated with
important co-benefits what are the core
benefits higher energy security lower
levels of pollution at the local level
protection of ecosystems and so on so
these core benefits unfortunately are
not monetized and perhaps some of them
can't be monetized but they are tangible
they are serious and I think they have
to be taken into account in policy
formulation let me go through this
quickly decarbonisation of electricity
generation for low-level stabilization
scenarios this will require renewables
nuclear CCS increased from thirty
percent today to more than eighty
percent by 2050 these are just some of
the scenarios that we have put forward
fossil fuel power generation without CCS
is phased out almost entirely by 2100 so
this is something that we see as part of
the scenario by which you stabilize the
climate and re technologies will take
off in a big way Nick nuclear could make
an increasing contribution to low-carbon
energy supply but there are barriers
there risks which have to be taken into
account replacement of current world
average coal-fired power plants with
modern highly efficient natural gas
combined cycle power plant or combined
heat power plants so the whole
efficiency of this supply system will
need to be altered substantially I won't
go into this let me skip this but here
is something that it might be of
interest to you this gives you some of
the costs of mitigation if let's say we
were to bring about mitigation at the
desired level to maintain temperature
increase to two degrees or below then
we've estimated the loss in global
consumption in 20 30 would be a median
value of one point seven percent of the
global gdp in 20 30 in 2050 it will be
three point four percent now if you look
at it this is really not a high price to
pay for the benefits of avoiding some of
the worst impacts of climate change not
to speak of the co-benefits which I
referred to which would accrue as a
result so anyone who says that the cost
will be substantial is obviously
ignoring this assessment and this
reality there's an increased focus on
policies designed to integrate multiple
objectives so you really need to bring
about improved energy efficiency and
security cleaner energy sources air
quality and human health so these are
just some of the core benefits
associated with mitigation and here I'd
like to highlight something on which
I've got a very brief film which I'll
show you in a minute the fact is that
there's a large part of the world where
you could use decentralized energy
supply systems based on renewables and
there are these niche markets which
actually amount to a substantial
opportunity you know they're 1.3 billion
people across the globe who have no
access to electricity and we can meet
their demand in an efficient clean way
by using renewable energy and here I'd
like to mention two quotations from
Gandhi a technological society has two
choices first it can wait until
catastrophic failures expose systemic
deficiencies distortion and
self-deceptions or it could we could
have a culture that
wyd social checks and balances to
correct for systemic distortion prior to
catastrophic failures and the second
quotation basically I mean if we're just
going to focus on GDP without looking at
what the impacts are going to be what
the externalities are that we're
burdening with all kinds of negative
factors then clearly that's of no value
that means speed is irrelevant if you
are going in the wrong direction so I'll
stop here and I'll request if that video
could be played that's just an
indication of how one can bring about
change at the grassroots level in some
of the poor parts of the world Thanks
yeah sure
thank you well while that's being loaded
I'll be very happy to take any brief
questions that you have yes sir hello
thank you for your talk and for your
work I think what is probably the most
important thing that my point could be
studying right now a lot of us here are
students and hopefully will enter the
workforce in a couple of years curious
from your perspective where are we most
needed like if we were going to have a
chance at addressing the climate changes
you talk about where should we be
focusing our efforts well it seems to me
this will be something that has to be
addressed by all stakeholders whether
you talk of government industry civil
society research and academia unless we
have a coalition of all stakeholders
we're not going to be able to surmount
this problem so I would say I mean in my
Institute we've set up a university
called the Terry University we have to
mba programs over there and the focus of
those is unsustainable development there
are some businesses that are getting
very conscious about this fact and the
need to move towards sustainable
business so i would say that there's a
whole range of activities where if you
have the right mindset if you have the
right skills you really are going to be
ahead of everybody else because whether
it's five years or ten years i have no
doubt in my mind that the world will be
thinking along those lines so my
submission would be that depending on
what your interests are don't hesitate
at all to pursue those interests but do
them within the framework of what would
give us a better and cleaner world are
we ready okay let's play this
chemistry tough life
you
you
you
so the thing is if we think out of the
box I'm sure we can find innovative ways
by which we can harness renewable low
emissions technologies for a whole range
of applications in an economically
viable way no questions
hi thank you for your talk I was just
wondering if you could talk a bit more
about future projections for monsoon
change and what that means at a regional
level with the low certainty yeah in the
working group one report we have come up
with projections on changes in the
monsoon actually it varies from across I
mean all of South Asia but one thing
that's becoming common across the whole
region is the fact that we have much
more heavy falls than we've seen in the
past and that clearly has implications
not only for safety but also in terms of
the the amount of water that would be
available because if the runoff is going
to be much larger in short periods of
time then clearly what recharged in
terms of groundwater resources what can
be impounded and stored would also have
to be looked at now one of the
adaptation measures as far as the
growing problem water scarcity is
concerned is much wider use of rainwater
harvesting and you would also need some
more different infrastructure that has
implications for energy supply from
hydroelectric projects as well because
the catchment area of these if it's
going to be affected by changes in
rainfall patterns then clearly that has
implications for the kind of
infrastructure you establish for
producing power from hydroelectric
stations
doctor which I shukriya again it's
really wonderful so you had mentioned
that the IPCC is not prescriptive and
its endeavors as this has climate change
worsens to envision that role changing
at all and if so in which direction I'm
sorry I didn't get the last part of your
question as climate change worsens do
you envision that role changing at all
if so in which no I don't think so
because you know frankly I mean it's bad
enough for us to be accused of being
policy prescriptive than we're not and
now if we become policy prescriptive
then god help us so and I think in order
to maintain its neutrality and I might
just mention that the IPCC of course
mobilizes the best scientific talent
from all over the world we don't pay
them anything people work as a labor of
love and they do it for the prestige for
the fact that they are contributing to
something that has global implications
and I I think one of the reasons why
despite all the reservations that people
have in accepting the the findings of
our assessments is the fact that there
is a certain level of neutrality that
people see the IPCC associated with now
be able to change that firstly it's
going to be very difficult to come up
with policy prescriptive suggestions
because they'll vary from place to paste
place and there is really nothing that
you can put forward as a silver bullet
there are problems there are
opportunities with everything that we do
so I don't see the role of the IPCC
changing it's going to remain policy
relevant but not policy prescriptive
thank you dr. Patrick so these wonderful
magnificent works by a pc see that are
presented in these reports are
unfortunately very dense and very
academic or difficult to understand for
the general public what is in your
opinion the most effective way to convey
the the challenges to the general public
so that we can get a very effective
change from the entire population well
firstly each assessment report has a
summary for policymakers which is
supposed to be written in simple
intelligible language perhaps that's not
always possible but I want to tell you
that every summary for policymakers has
to be accepted by all the government's
who are sitting in that room for almost
a week sometimes through the nights
going through every word of the text
that's presented and often the kind of
the most often the kind of response you
get from the country delegations is why
are you saying this and then the authors
have to defend why and then they say
okay I understand number why don't you
put it in somewhat different language
because my Minister won't understand
what you're saying over here so we do
modify the language but despite that
frankly a lot of technical jargon does
remain over there now it's for this
reason that we bring out something
called the synthesis report which will
be coming out in October and that's a
very slim document and that also has the
summary for policymakers despite that I
mean I should be candid that it's not
something that you would get the manager
/ 7-eleven store to understand I mean
the highest respect that I have for
7-eleven stores because they bail you
out when you need them the most but
but the truth is that they probably are
not meant for people who have a certain
level of education which is certainly
not something to be negligent of but I
think they're what we really need is
partnerships and that in was the media
that involves NGOs that involves a whole
lot of organizations who can take the
findings of the IPCC reports and convert
them into language that most people will
understand now that's something the IPCC
can't do by definition but others can
and we're trying much more this time
around to see that we engage people to
take our message converted to do
something that people will understand
even school kids I mean you need books
that are illustrative that are simple
for school kids to understand because
you go to you've got to cater to every
section of society including the next
generation thank you dr. Pachauri arm
it's always great to see Mothma gandhi's
reinterpreted in your presentations as
we see these challenges go forward my
question is maybe I hope he's blessing
me wherever he is because most people
have forgotten him and I three was a man
ahead of his time falling that the point
do you think I do you see the role how
do you see the role of developing
countries per se in taking lead in
reducing the impacts of climate change
or for that matter even showing the path
for solving this problem well I'm
increasingly of the view that the
developing countries have to sort of
take the lead it would be utterly
foolish I mean you've seen the little
film that I presented you could have
these people in villages wait till they
get an extension of the grid why is
coming into their homes and that'll
probably take another three generations
before they could get reliable
and regular supply of power but on the
other hand you can jump-start the whole
business and use technologies that are
now on the horizon so I think we need to
think out of the box we need to think
differently and I'm sorry you probably
heard this quote before when Gandhi was
asked whether he wouldn't want India to
be as prosperous as Britain his answer
was it took Britain to use half the
resources of this planet to reach its
level of prosperity he said how many
planets would a country like India
require and that's the point I mean why
should we follow a resource intensive
path of development I mean China is 1.4
billion people India is getting there
and will probably surpass it very soon
because we don't have the one-child norm
and you know people are pretty
productive at least in expanding the
population and therefore you know we
really cannot pursue the same path of
development it would be utterly foolish
to replicate what's happened in the rest
of the world however let me tell you
when you talk to the leadership in our
part of the world is there why should we
be denied all the good things of
development well we have a certain
culture we have a tradition we've got
thousands of years of history let's
build on that and make the most of the
opportunities that we have thank you um
as we ask imma change the effects of
climate change start being felt and we
move from mitigation to adaptation is
there any worry that countries will
start looking within themselves for
resilience and maybe give up on the
mitigation route and just pursue
adaptation within their own local
regions no we've made it very very clear
that it cannot be one or the other it
has to be both because if in the working
group to report we brought out very
clearly that you would reach a level of
impacts of climate change when
adaptation
we'll just not work it there will be
certain thresholds there will be certain
tipping points beyond which adaptation
will be extremely challenging so I think
countries will have to pursue a path of
both both adapting and mitigating
nothing short of that is going to work
and I think that's a message which comes
out very clearly in the fifth assessment
report I see the president of the
university year so maybe I should I I
should shut up mark over to you alright
so let's just let me introduce Peter
salad a the president of Yale University
as a few remarks
so good afternoon everybody I hope the
day has been an interesting one for you
i wish i could have been here to see it
but i thought but i did want to come for
the end of this afternoon because i'm
really on behalf of the whole university
we wanted to take a moment to honor
patchy who has been a terrific partner
for several years let me let me tell you
the story i think some of you know it
and others of you may not the climate
and energy institute really started as a
faculty project in 2007 the idea was an
institute devoted to research teaching
on issues at the intersection of climate
energy science came together really
through a kind of grow organically came
about through faculty like Dave
bercovici and Mark Pagani getting their
colleagues excited about about
potentially collaborative first sharing
of ideas and then and then maybe
research but you may remember those of
you who yell ease that in two thousand
eight the next June dr. Pachauri was
honored with an honorary degree yell and
so many of us who knew him by reputation
actually got to meet him on that
occasion and on that occasion we read a
citation about him and I'll read it to
you now it's very brief as a leading
voice on climate change you've been a
builder of bridges from scientific
evidence to public policy from developed
to developing countries as author of one
of the major first major reports on
global warming you helped lay the
foundation for the Kyoto protocols of
1997 and as a leader of the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change you have brought the world
scientific community together to sound
the alarm about the future of our planet
you combine a deep respect for science
with passion to protect our environment
yells privileged to have you as a
collaborator with our school of Forestry
environmental studies and pleased to
award you the degree of Doctor of Humane
Letters that was the that was the 2008
interaction now people up here in
forestry already knew dr. Pachauri but
that was when met the rest of us really
got a chance to meet him so 2009 I think
president 11 got the great idea that why
not have dr. Pachauri and this fledgling
yci institute intersect each other and
dr. Pachauri was named the first
director of yci yce I and we appointed
him as professor in the practice of
sustainable sustainable development up
here in the school of Forestry and
environmental studies and for the next
several years as you know he has split
his time between Terry and in Delhi
where he's been the director general
since 1981 and the intergovernmental
panel on climate change which he's
chaired since 2002 and us and I think
which is which is a handful no doubt
about it I think you know Terry since
1981 is India's most prominent center
for research and education in the field
of sustainable development but really is
is a global institution so when we
looked at the years well well dr.
Pretoria has been the director of why
CEI we can see the accomplishments of
the group see grants have been given for
scholarly research the postdoctoral
fellowship program began very robust set
of workshop and speakers workshops and
speakers and of course the annual
conference since 2012 he's remained on
the faculty steering committee for yci
and become the senior advisor to yce is
external advisory board let me give you
some of the accomplishments in just a
little bit more detail those sea grants
have involved two million dollars 20
projects 50 faculty members 15 different
yell departments I think many of you
know how hard that is to do there's also
been more than five million dollars in
external funding from NSF from
Department of Energy and other sources
they've been 18 different postdocs from
13 different universities they've worked
in nine departments and schools at Yale
they've been five annual conferences
they've been 12 workshops and forums the
energy science institute out on the west
campus was established and funded by a
very generous gift and is generally
thought to be an outgrowth of y SI è I
now has a nice collaborative partnership
with y cai over the next period of time
will be drafting a report on what is
leading it over on this campus in the
area of sustainability and i know dr.
Pachauri ideas are going to influence us
as we think about the northeast as we
think about Connecticut as we think
about New Haven and how Yale needs to
respond I think why CA I many of you
have heard me talk about a more unified
yell right that's one of my themes of
the new presidency and I always use yce
I yce I as an example of a more unified
yell that predates anything I had to say
on the topic right it is a wonderful
example of faculty coming together from
all parts of the University and to to do
collaborative research and teaching and
to influence practice and I think that
has happened in large part because of
the inspiration and the leadership that
dr. Pachauri
has provided so to show the university's
appreciation we have a little gift for
you and does any have that gift is that
there it is okay now this is this is
subtle okay what is this right a hockey
stick why is this right we all know the
famous graph but this is more than just
a analog representation of the those
data on climate change but it is also a
souvenir from the National the NCAA
national champion Yale hockey team last
year were number one in the country it
is signed by president 11 by me by our
hockey coach but also by the founding
members of Y CEI who may never have
played hockey in their life but
recognized recognize the challenge that
global warning warming presents to ice
hockey
so what is what is now happening is this
hockey stick is actually being
circulated in the climate change
community for additional signatures and
in fact is on its way to Michael Mann
and I think many of you know Michael
Mann is the person who did that research
whose hockey stick data shaped data on
global temperature rise were just so
influential and getting people like me
psychologists who don't work in this
field to recognize what a serious
problem climate change in fact is going
to be so we will lend this to you for
the purposes of this ceremony then take
it back from you get the rest of the
signatures and then ship it to you but
patchy thank you so much for all that
you've done guys thank you so much great